hello everyone thanks for the
introduction team I am just want i'll be
talking about parallel javascript before
i tell you more about it wipe parallel
javascript well simple the hardware you
have is getting more and more parallel
you have more and more cores on your
processors you have wider vector units
your GPUs are increasing in performance
rapidly since 2006 there's been a 75 x
increase in performance of Intel GPUs
there's abundant client-side parallelism
that JavaScript applications don't use
today at the same time the kinds of
applications you would write with
JavaScript has changed now you have
physics and fluid simulations you have
path tracing real-time game engines at
the same time JavaScript programs have
access to device sensors on both sensors
multimedia streams so the kinds of
applications are changing they're
becoming more sophisticated more compute
intensive right but there is no support
for parallel computing but why do we
want to invent a new parallel
programming model wide there are already
so many so many people have invented so
many why don't we just take one and bolt
it on top of JavaScript right so it
turns out that the web has specified
requirements requirements that that make
this approach happened is undesirable
first thing we want to preserve is ease
of use so this whatever programming
parallel programming model we introduce
should be should fit in well with the
rest of JavaScript so the programmer
shouldn't have to have two different
mental models one for sequential if one
for the sequential parts of the program
and mal for the parallel processing
program it should all just be JavaScript
we want to have a very high level API we
don't want the programming to worry
about compare and exchange primitives or
atomic intrinsic or even threads right
we want to have a very high level API in
fitting with the with the ethos of
JavaScript
and we want to be deterministic where
possible this is hard for parallel
programming in general but the
determinism is awesome for debugging and
deployment so we want to preserve that
we also want to be platform independent
we want to run on all kinds of platforms
from single core mobile phones to the
most powerful desktop computer and we
also want to leverage different kinds of
parallelism on these platforms so it
could be multi-core parallelism GPU
parallelism or simdi parallelism not
just that we want to we want the
programmer to write the same code for
all of these different kinds of
parallelism in other words we don't want
the programmer to write one kind of code
for multi-core CPUs another one for GPUs
and so on we want that to be abstracted
way our goal is to extract reasonable
performance from parallel hardware
extracting all performance out of power
hardware is a secondary goal and this
this should not be completely up to the
developer it the browser runtime should
share a lot of this burden of extracting
performance so we want to make the
expression of parallelism easy but not
necessarily how you actually implement
it finally we want to make it suitable
for the open web we want to with what we
don't want to increase the attack
surface for javascript in other words we
don't want native execution of native
code for example we still want to
preserve the kind of a sandboxed
execution environment of javascript
right so this is a brief overview of the
parallel JavaScript API it's built on
three pillars the first is collections
these collections in JavaScript are just
JavaScript arrays and typed objects
which are going to be in es7 then you
have high level data parallel methods
that operate on these collections some
of these may already be familiar to you
right Map Reduce filter scatter the
power suffix simply conveys the
programmers intention that he would like
this part this method call to operate in
parallel right it may not as we will see
but he would like it to be so very high
level no threads
the third component is elemental
functions these are these are just
regular JavaScript functions that are
the things that are executed in parallel
across cores on GPUs and so on but
there's one important caveat they have
to be side-effect free that is they
cannot alter global state so a global
state may for example be a global
variable right you in a parallel region
you cannot you know in elemental
function you cannot change global state
right you can read it but you cannot
write to it there are also more subtle
kinds of side effects in JavaScript
programs which are engine level side
effects right so for example just
concatenate in two strings even though
it appears at a surface level as a
side-effect free operation has engine
level side effects okay but it's not up
to the programmer to worry about those
things right it's up to the browser
runtime to worry about that so let's
look at some code examples this is a
very simple example of how you would use
the map power you have a tiny array one
two three four and then you just give it
give map power an elemental function
which is that that fat arrow function
over there and it increments each
element in the in the input array so
this looks exactly like map part map
right if you just wrote this using map
it would look exactly the same the
difference here is this the elemental
function is executed in parallel for
each element in this array so if of
course in this case you don't need
parallelism because it's only four
elements but if you have a million
elements and your elemental function is
doing something more sophisticated you
can imagine how this would be useful
right reduced looks very similar you
give it again a elemental function that
takes two values and returns one value
so you're reducing a and B to produce a
plus B and when applied to this array it
produces 10 this is exactly the
semantics of of reduce the normal jobs
can produce as well right so just by
adding power you're making it parallel
right however there is an important
caveat here determinism in when you do
when you do reduce the term
nism is guaranteed only when the
elemental function is associated right
if the elemental function is not
associative then you will get you will
transparently get sequential execution
so it will be equal in to just reduce so
in other words you the programmer does
the best job you can to write code that
is parallelism friendly if not he will
just if it's not parallelism friendly he
will just transparently get sequential
execution right without any without
changing any code so let's say have a
input image which is a three dimensional
width x height x 4 right 4 is RGB alpha
this is how you would convert it into
grayscale you just do a map par ignore
the two over there and you would just
give it an elemental function that that
average is the first three channels the
RGB values and returns a array with this
so this is a simple averaging gray scale
operation the two here is the depth at
which you want this map power to operate
so if you have a three dimensional
collection you will sometimes you would
like to operate on rows of an image
sometimes you would like to operate on
pixels in an image and so on sometimes
you would even not like to operate on
individual channels color channels in an
image so the depth parameter allows you
to kind of select what slice you want to
do this parallel operation on in an
input collection okay so you don't have
to worry about all the details you can
read the document later but just just to
give you an idea of what the API looks
like so reversing an array a simple
example you create an array using the
build power API this in parallel it
constructs an array of length 4 that
just contains 0 1 2 3 and scatter power
takes a function that map's elements in
the input array two indices in the
output array so in this case Katter
power is just taking the first element
putting it in the last index and so on
right filtering filter works exactly the
same way as
filter power works exactly the same way
as JavaScript filter side integral you
just give it an elemental function that
returns a boolean and the boolean
decides whether the value stays in the
output array or not typed objects are a
new proposal for xscape 7 I believe
they're already there there is a
preliminary implementation in Firefox
and the API just works on typed objects
identically to JavaScript objects so
it's the exact same gray scale operation
that I showed you earlier it's it's very
similar except instead of returning a
JavaScript array you're returning a new
type object okay so this is what i mean
by fitting in with the rest of
javascript right you don't want to
introduce new types you don't want to
introduce new kind of concepts you want
to kind of build upon what is already
there parallel javascript is a es7
proposal at this point we're discussing
the API in the committee and with
browser renders there is a specification
that you can look at and a preliminary
implementation is in Firefox nightly and
the API that I've just shown you is kind
of a is the result of a collaboration
between mighty men and the mozilla team
that is implementing pjs in nightly so
in order to get power little execution
they had this solve of several
challenges I'll briefly describe them
first was JIT support so you want for
parallelism you want to guarantee
side-effect freedom how do you guarantee
that things don't mutate global state
right with the way they do that do this
is they have a static safety analysis
that inspects your JavaScript and and
figures out whether there is a violation
of the side of side effect freedom
requirement they also have right cards
which are dynamic checks that check
whether you're following the the rule
they have a pretty cool work stealing
scheduler that that tries to schedule
work on to Hardware threads in a way
that reduces imbalance among
so basically it tries to keep all of
your hardware threads so if you have
hyper threading you have many Hardware
threads it tries to keep all of them
busy and there's a new garbage
collection scheme just for parallel
JavaScript that is kind of integrated
with the spider monkey firefox's
generational garbage collector and the
cool thing about this is that it
actually exploits the programming model
the property of the programming model
which is that you can't have side
effects and this fact makes garbage
collection fast turns out which is cool
and finally there's a lot of work on
providing detailed reasons for why
something did not execute in parallel so
for example in the map map power example
that I showed earlier if i were to
insert some dom operation for example
which is not side-effect free then the
program will bail out of parallel
execution and you will just get
sequential execution but your console
will tell you that this is the operation
at this line number in your program that
is the reason for you not getting
parallel speed ups right they also
provide complete stack frames at bailout
points so that you can actually debug
why things didn't run in parallel this
is really important finally I would like
to take a few minutes to talk about
parallel JavaScript on GPUs GPUs are a
hugely important resource that I think
we should we should use more in
JavaScript programs in the non graphical
portions of JavaScript program so I mean
gpgpu general-purpose GPU programming
context but compiling parallel
JavaScript two GPUs is is not easy it's
challenging so I'll kind of outline a
few reasons why GPUs typically have a
separate address space than the CPU so
your JavaScript heap which is sitting on
the CPU right how do you make that
available to a JavaScript program
running on the GPU you have to copy it
which would be hugely expensive
but otherwise you would have to map it
somehow so this is a non-trivial problem
also it's even though in some new chips
physical memory shared virtual memory is
not shared right so this makes the
problem of mapping non-contiguous parts
of your heap to the device very very
challenging then there are a number of
paths to the actual GPU hardware there
is direct text there is glsl shaders
their open seal kernels and I'm sure
there are tons more each of these has
slightly different semantics and each of
these is allows a different subset of
JavaScript so I'm talking about
compiling JavaScript to one of these
right so as you can imagine you can
compile a different subset of JavaScript
to each of these so you have to kind of
reconcile all of these things together
if in your browser runtime so some
things that would be possible to express
in let's say opencl would not be
possible to express an OpenGL right just
because of the of the programming model
so you have to kind of keep that in mind
when you're compiling then there is no
dynamic allocation on most GPUs there is
no notion of a heap as such it's just
scratchpad memory the star there
indicates that on kind of more recent
GPUs there is actually I think CUDA two
point O has malik but it's not widely
implemented on all GPUs forget heap
there is no general notion of a stack
either right on a GPU so most
interesting JavaScript programs would
like to do he publications I presume so
this would be kind of hard to support so
you what you would have to build a
dynamic memory manager and a collector
that runs completely on the GPU there
are also no function pointers in most
GPU programming models this makes things
like dynamic dispatch difficult to
implement and polymorphism is also
difficult to implement and finally
getting performance is not always easy
/ has to kind of keep track of different
families of gpus ok this is a fourth
generation GPU with this open CL and so
on and this is a CUDA GPU with this
version of kudos oh so this is it's very
it's it's it's an intractable problem
and it's it's unreasonable to expect the
programmer to kind of keep track of all
of these things so our approach is to
basically take this high level
specification in pjs and let the browser
runtime figure all the the browser
runtime has perfect knowledge of what
the platform is right it can query GPU
capabilities it can it can do all of
that so the idea is to just let the
browser one time do it transparently so
we have actually implemented a back-end
that takes your JavaScript and compiles
it to run on GPU and we will let
implemented it with in Firefox so this
is a overview of what it looks like so
the blue parts are just what would
happen with normal parallel JavaScript
execution on the CPU so you would run
for a little while in the interpreter in
the baseline JIT and once your code has
been hit a few times it's hot and you
know all the type information then you
would go to the Iron Monkey jet which
would spend more time trying to optimize
your code it is at this point that you
would do your parallel safety analysis
that is checking whether something is
actually safe to run in parallel or not
right after that you would just lower it
a few times and then you just get native
code right in the GPU case we take Mir
which is the mid level intermediate
representation of JavaScript in Iron
Monkey and we do GPU specific safety
analysis so this basically checks
whether your weather all the byte codes
in your JavaScript program can be
supported on the GPU so for example if
you're compiling to glsl then maybe some
particular byte codes are not supported
right you there are no equivalence in
glsl for some JavaScript byte code right
then we do some simple type inference
this is basically taking the JIT Iron
Monkey Jets type information and
translating it into types that opencl
understands and we do some up
musicians for exploiting local memory
which is very fast on GPUs and then
finally region just generate opencl and
then this opencl is built into a GPU
binary and we cache that binary and we
use that binary whenever this as long as
type information doesn't change as the
types flowing through your JavaScript
program don't change this Colonel is
valid and we just keep reusing it so
let's so what does what does all of this
buyers right let's look at the energy
and and let's look at performance first
versus parallel execution on a cpu right
so remember the bass line here is
powered parallel JavaScript execution on
a cpu which is already depending on how
many cores you have which is already
faster than regular sequential
JavaScript right so the blue axis the
blue y-axis is performance relative to
parallel execution on cpu so these are
some these are some simple benchmarks
that I picked we have more I can show
them to you later so this mm is dense
matrix multiply it does eight times
better on on the GPU then on parallel
CPU so this is written in JavaScript
using pjs right and to deconvolution
which you use for things like image
sharpening or image or finding contours
or optical flow or things like that tony
kahn relation is a fairly important
algorithm that does 2.8 times faster on
GPU then on parallel cpu and Mandelbrot
is a simple you all know the Mandelbrot
set it is 6.2 times better in terms of
performance than CPU what about energy
so for dense matrix multiply GPU
execution is seven point seven times
lower in energy than CPU execution than
parallel CP execution similarly to
deconvolution is three times and
Mandelbrot is seven point seven times
lower so not only are you getting huge
increases
and performance from parallel execution
and GPU / what is already pretty fast
parallel CPU right you're also at the
same time getting huge decreases in
total energy consumption right this is
big so just for reference the matrix
multiply program I believe runs compared
to sequential JavaScript the CPU version
20 runs 22 times faster so this a tech
8x is over that right on GPU so that
that's just to give you an idea to
deconvolution is probably like six times
faster than sequential JavaScript and
this would be to 2.8 times faster than
that okay let me quickly show you a
quick demo this is a simple program
so there there are a bunch of bugs and
the goal of the game is to move them
using my hand to the frog feed them to
the frog or take them to their house
right so I probably should be standing
closer so it's using its doing optical
flow on the image stream captured by the
camera to basically figure out where I'm
which way I'm moving so you can see all
the books settling on my face so it
basically detects changes in energy in
the image so if I were to just run the
sequential version of this today it
would run like this right this is this
is pretty slow let's go back to the
parallel version
so let me go back to my presentation I
can show this to you in more detail if
you're interested ok so the
implementation is in Firefox nightly
there is a acma script proposal we would
very much like your feedback this is the
time to kind of influence what the API
looks like and how it is specified so if
you have any comments please write to me
or just participate in the discussion on
es discuss and try it out and let us
know what you think thank you